there's this idea that
in order for meditation to be most
effective you have to sit up straight
and you have to cross your legs that
hasn't been my experience getting back
to the easy approach easy is an acronym
for how you handle your your mental and
Sensational experiences e stands for
embrace a stands for accept s for
surrender Y and yield to so what are you
embracing accepting surrendering to and
yielding to all of your mental emotional
even physical
experiences during the meditation so if
you have an itch you scratch it if you
get uncomfortable you switch your
position so that you remain comfortable
if you have thoughts about work that's
amazing when you are seeing your mind as
an ally and not the enemy of the
practice that place you want to go to
the place where everybody wants to go to
the calmness the quietness the deepness
that's where you go